hello everyone welcome to the to today's
live broadcast a new generation and
angry new athletes presented by dr.
David Borden I am Marjorie Taurus of
laberd's and I will be your moderator
for today's event we are excited to
bring you this educational web seminar
presented by libraries and sponsored by
thermo Fisher Scientific before we begin
I'd like to remind everyone that this
presentation is interactive we want to
hear from you questions comments and
even answers can be submitted via degree
in Q&A button at the lower left of your
screen we'll try to get to everyone but
if not we'll make sure to follow up with
you by email you can also enlarge the
slide window by clicking on the screen
icon in the lower right hand corner of
the slide window if you cannot hear or
see this presentation properly let us
know by clicking on the support button
at the top right of the Q&A button in
the lower left I will now turn the
presentation over to dr. David Boren hi
everyone
thanks for joining today I'm really
excited to be speaking with you today my
name is David Borden and I've been with
the company for about eight years
focusing on next-generation immunoassay
platforms across the biomarker discovery
as well as validation spaces I'm very
excited to speak with you today about an
innovative platform that we've developed
over the last several years this work
was conducted in close collaboration
with multiple interdisciplinary groups
across our organization and also what's
exciting is this is also the product of
a lot of very close interactions with
with various immunoassay users not only
in the US but across the world and so
through that that interaction and
through that sensing and asking people
what they really needed and working with
people in the translational research
space or biomarker discovery space my
colleagues and I have learned a lot
about what people need these
is what their demands are and what's
going to make their work easier as well
as more powerful when it comes to
publishing and basically furthering
biomedical research I have the pleasure
of sharing this platform with you today
but let me say that on this platform and
the innovative work behind it is really
the the product of a lot of hard work
from many people not only the the
talented research and development team
that I lead but also my close colleagues
across the gamut you know product
management marketing program management
and as well as leadership army
leadership and business leadership have
all been very supportive of this
technology and I really want to express
my appreciation and just say that what
we're talking about today is is a
contribution of a lot of people so I
want to say hats off to everyone for
this great work so let's get started so
in slide 2 what we see here is basically
just a wireframe diagram on the left
side of the union system various cell
types and the extracellular mediators
cytokines growth factors etc my
background is in GPCR signaling so when
I look at a wireframe diagram like this
I get excited about all the different
ways in which these extracellular
mediators can play it's definitely not a
single linear process right many of
these inflammatory modulators have
multiple roles and I think that's what
makes the the amino manned studying
inflammation very exciting but also very
challenging and so on the right-hand
side in this slide I'm showing a number
of different immunoassay tools that our
company has developed and I've had the
pleasure of working with different
talented teams focusing on the Western
workflow be based amino acids from the
pro Carter Plex
and other luminex assay platforms as
well as I'll flow in imaging and so let
me just say that my goal of showing this
slide is really to impress upon everyone
to use the right tool at the right time
we have a lot of different amino acids
out there but they're not all ideal be
using all the time and so I think even
today's presentation is is focused on
when to use those right tools and I'll
get to that in just a minute with the
single Plex but a lot of the
translational researchers and biomarker
discovery enthusiasts had adopted this
discovery to validation workflow in
which one uses a high content technology
for example maybe mass spec or a high
content protein microarray to discover
targets but then as those targets get
verified with other orthogonal platforms
and other maybe functional assays the
relevance of that target and whether or
not it's truly involved in the
particular physiological process that's
being studied is further refined but
then it comes then it sort of I think
let me just say that the the ultimate
significance of a biomarker or a
particular analytes that's being
associated with a disease progression
really gets fully vetted at the single
Plex or what I'm calling the validation
step here and that step is where
basically the technology that's used is
a single Plex technology that arm can be
done in high throughput can be done very
rapidly it needs very little samples
you're not consuming a lot of your
precious Syrah for example and that's
where if you look at this discovery de
validation diagram here the single Plex
platforms where there's been a lot of
activity around trying to make more
innovative and more novel platforms and
I'm sure you've seen a lot of activity
in the last couple years in this space
there
a lot of activity but there's still a
lot of needs have gone unmet and so my
colleagues and I have set out to really
execute upon this to make sure that the
single plex platform that we deliver
addresses a lot of those a lot of those
needs and so today what I'd like to
unveil is the the pro quantum
immunoassay platform - - tivity
immunoassay platform and what's
wonderful about quantum and I really am
excited about this because I think a
large company like Thermo Fisher
Scientific has so many areas of
expertise and but even in in a in our
space it's very easy to kind of work in
a and on I would say a silo but very
easy to work within a certain discipline
but really I think some of the greatest
innovations and some of the greatest
contributions are when people step
outside of their initial comfort zone
and think of new ways to tackle
challenging problems I believe that's
what we've done here so what for quantum
does is it combines the power of matched
antibody pairs with the sensitivity and
broad dynamic range of qpcr it's
important to note here that in our
company we're well known for our
proteomic technologies and of course our
pac-man genomic technologies and so
naturally putting these two key areas
together is bound to to address some
some core needs and these needs are as
follows in the latter part of this slide
so first of all - tivity through many of
you out there that are looking for early
detection of inflammatory mediators you
know that it's very important to
understand very subtle changes we're
talking sensor grams per mil changes
between let's say a disease population
and a healthy age match control so what
we've done is we've produced a platform
that grades gives a great sensitivity I
mentioned just a minute ago about sample
consumption we know that many of these
samples are very precious they're
they're irreplaceable in some
and so being able to get a lot of great
data very powerful data out of a very
small sample is a huge contribution and
it's something that everyone asks for
because of course if you have a limited
amount of sample you want to get as much
great data out of that sample as
possible and what we've done is we've
addressed that with a sample volume of
between two and five microliters and
I'll go through in just a minute as to
why there's a range there but again as
low as two microliters for multiple
replicates or a readout on this third
bullet point fast and easy workflow this
is something that I think I know it's
semantics but you know many times people
talk about sample the result and I see a
difference between result and answer the
result may just be the numerical value
but the answer really is whether or not
something is statistically different
than another and actually what I'm going
to do today is I'm going to provide a
live demo of our new innovative cloud
platform so that we've devised a design
our own software to go with this
platform and I'll show how it works in
just a bit but being able to not only
set up the assay and run it but then
also get your final answer get
statistically relevant comparisons in a
very short amount of time is really
important for you to be able to
understand what experiment you do next
broad dynamic range that is something
that I think anybody who's run an assay
that maybe only has two maybe three logs
of dynamic range knows that if your
unknown doesn't hit your standard curve
the first time what's the first thing
you have to do rerun that sample at a
different dilution and what we've done
is we provided a platform that easily
has five logs of dynamic range so what
that helps ensure is that the first time
you run this assay is the last time you
have to run it for that particular study
um just as important is with a lot of
these new immunoassay platforms many of
them require a very expensive instrument
and what we've done is we capitalized on
the fact that nearly I'd say you know
many many labs have
you see our instruments and this
platform runs on real-time PCR
instrumentation so even if you don't
have the instrument in your lab chances
are somebody in your hallway has that
that instrument so you can actually try
it for yourself and see how this
platform works without having to request
a demo or purchase an expensive
instrument that can only be used for one
type of of workflow and then finally
this cloud software this is an area
where I think myself as a protein
biochemist by training it's really
exciting for me to work with skilled
software developers in our company who
helped take our vision of what we want
the workflow to look like and what the
end user needs and how quickly they need
it we've been able to make that reality
and I hope to show you that in this live
demo and I think you'll be very
impressed now first of all let me just
kind of go through a very high level
what is Pro quantum um it's a proximity
based assay platform in which you still
have two antibodies one antibody is
conjugated to a five-prime or a three
primal ago so there are two different
epitopes specific antibodies each with a
different a logo conjugated to it and so
just like a traditional immunoassay
platform there are two epitope specific
antibodies as well as the analyte of
interest so what happens is upon mixture
of the analyte in your sample and the
two epitope specific antibodies these
antibodies basically bind analyte and
the ala goes become stabilized then in
the presence of DNA ligase and cycling
conditions basically on the 60 mer in
the four-team arm basically create a
single strand DNA template that can then
be amplified through 40 cycles of qpcr
so essentially the more analyte in the
sample the more bridging of all of those
occurs the more bridging of ala goes
creates more qpcr templates and more
qpcr template
leads to a faster application of the
template strand and so this all uses kak
man genomic technology and I'm not going
to go through all of it in the interest
of time today but essentially the more
DNA template you have the more
fluorescence you produce in a shorter
number of cycles so I will be referring
to CP which is the cycle number to reach
threshold so again the more excuse me
the more analyte that is present in your
sample the more antibody binding that
occurs and that's proportional of course
the amount of analyte to the lung
standard curves just like any other
immunoassay but then the number of cycle
to reach threshold is a lower number
when there is more analyte present and
vice-versa
as shown in this figure on the far right
slide of a figure of slide 5 so what we
see here is actually real data from our
il-10 assay NPC is the no protein
control and so with no protein present
only the antibodies with the conjugated
to DNA Allah goes the system requires 31
cycles the rich threshold but then as
you titer in Aisle 10 the number of
cycle to reach threshold goes down in a
very predictable manner now if we go
ahead and subtract out the no protein
control or subtract out the background
we get it inverse and so basically this
curve in the bottom right corner is very
similar very recognizable to us in the
immunoassay space as the beginning of a
sigmoidal curve and so it's a very
predictable and very good fitting curve
that uses five parameter logistic
regression and so the pro quantum
immunoassay kit actually there are a
number of different benefits that we
have worked on the power of the acid
platform I'll go through in just a
minute but also like I mentioned the
simplicity so we wanted to make sure
that there are very few number
files in the entire kit so what you see
here on the left side is an actual
photograph of the packaging and on the
right side is a cartoon that explains
what they are so like any other email
app a platform there is a protein
standard that is used to to generate a
standard curve and then an assay
dilution buffer that is used to not only
reconstitute and dilute the protein
standard but also to dilute your unknown
samples now unique to pro quantum what
we've done is we've kept antibody a and
antibody B with the different all go
separate just to ensure quality so
actually the user combines antibody a
and antibody B and the dilution buffer
all together right before they use it so
that's just a simple quick pipetting
stuff to combine all three and then
finally also unique to pro quantum is
this master mix and ligase we've
actually combined all the key components
for TaqMan amplification as well as the
DNA ligase which helps create the
initial first strand so here's the
workflow and so at the top are what I'm
showing is a typical iliza workflow that
most of you should be familiar with you
can see here the time frame the number
of steps and I think what I want to
point out here it's what we've done is
we have greatly improved upon of the
handling the number of hands-on steps
and it's important to note right here
that this is actually a homogeneous
assay so the first step in the assay is
actually just to create your standard
curve dilute your unknowns and place
them in the plate um in this particular
assay I'm showing the five microliter
reaction which is basically and I'll
explain very briefly right here um the
user takes their unknowns 5 microliters
each arm and then dilutes them on to 10%
so basically 5 + 45 they dilute their
their unknowns and place them in the
plate
of course also the standard curve is
generated and placed in this plate
everything incubates for one hour at
room temp then with a couple minutes
left before the user takes the master
mix and ligase mixes it together and
adds it right on top of the existing TCR
plate there is no washing on no
transfers etc so after the master mix is
added and it's a 40 microliter Edition
arm after that basically they reseal the
plate put it back into the instrument
for the ligation and 40 cycles of qPCR
so at the end of the 40 cycle the qPCR
basically the CT values are calculated
so it's important to note here that this
platform works with not only our applied
Biosystems family of instruments but it
works with any qPCR instrument any
instrument you have that generates a CT
value will work with pro quantum so
after the 40 cycles of qPCR the CT
values are transferred to your cloud
account and by the way if you have one
of our new cloud enabled qs3 or qs5
instruments that information actually
goes directly from the instrument
directly to your cloud account
seamlessly and so at the end of that
transfer it takes about five minutes and
actually i'll show you during the live
demo how quickly the data analysis can
occur now it's important to note here
that this platform is also very flexible
and what I mean by that I talked a
little bit about volumes of sample now
in this initial example here I'm talking
about a 5 micro liter sample but
actually our kit is very flexible and
what I mean by that is if something
doesn't have 5 microliters of sample
they can actually use a 2 microliters
sample so again you would create your
10% sample so you take 2 microliters and
you would add it to 18 microliters and
then 2 microliters of that 10% solution
is used per well so when you perform
that type of work
blow our single catalogue number will be
enough material for you to run to 96
well plates so the way this works out
and the reason we did this is we know
some people really want to stretch their
kit as far as they can and so for those
people we provided the workflow and by
the way our entire app a platform was
developed on the two microliter volume
but if you're an individual that's just
getting used to the technology and
actually wants to up the volume a little
bit just for pipetting comfort you can
still run a 5 micro liter assay we
provide enough material for that it's
just that you only get one plates worth
out of the kit and by the way for people
that are automation savvy or really want
to stretch the envelope of their kit
this same catalog number will also be
enough material to run one 384-well
plate so at that point you can see that
the price per data point really goes
down and then also for people that have
said well what if I want to run more
than one player walks other options of
yes there are and this is a a great a
great innovation and by the way it's
important to note that we have worked
very closely with the outside of our
business or the side of our corporation
that is the Catman genomic experts and
so what we've done is we've designed
this so that you can actually run the
step one and this step two on multiple
plates at once
and so basically instead of just running
one play you could let they run ten
plates on templates for the one-hour
intubation and then what you do is you
basically add the master mix and ligase
but only do a batch ligation so again 25
degrees for 20 minutes followed by a
ligase inactivation for two minutes and
95 degrees at that point the two minutes
at 95 what has happened is essentially
the antibodies and the analyte are
completely denatured and what's elegant
about this is that it from this point
onward it's nothing more than a DNA
readout and of course because DNA is
very stable
the
use plate let's say the user ran ten
plates they can all be stored and then
run at a later time in batch for example
if you're a user that has one of our
twister arms that is basically working
in conjunction with a quant studio
instrument you can actually read
multiple plates at once and because it's
only a DNA readout assay and you don't
need to be concerned about the presence
of antibodies or analyte anymore this
can actually be done at a later time
with greater flexibility um you know
temperature maintenance is not an issue
at that point so again this is a great
flexible option for those that are
trying to get higher throughput and
basically those that are trying to
compare Pro quantum with other
technologies that may have throughput
benefits so I think it's a great
solution for those users as well so what
I'm showing here is basically in slide
10 is a snapshot of our quick reference
card and so what we'll see from this
quick reference card is that really gone
are the days of having to read you know
a 10 or 20 page manual to get the gist
of how the acid works and so I think
from seeing the next two slides you'll
say wow this is really easy so the first
step is to reconstitute the protein
standard for stability reasons we
provide lyophilized protein and so on
the size of the vial will be the
reconstitution directions and so the
user basically takes a certain amount of
the acid dilution buffer and adds it to
the vial and then waits for 15 minutes
and during that 15 minute time period
the protein is refolding rehydrating etc
during those 15 minutes the user can
then go ahead and start making their
working plate what I mean by working
plate is essentially what we're doing is
we're encouraging people to think
differently about how they set up their
immunoassays I think we want to get away
from the days of digging through an ice
bucket and looking for your various
random vials and trying to figure out
which file goes with which step and
things like that so what we've done is
we've designed a working
and I know it seems like an easy concept
a lot of people just don't do it and so
what we do with a working plate is we
encourage people to be very organized
about the assay set up not only does it
lead to better organization but also it
maintains everything cold so we actually
refer people to a little aluminum cold
block that you store in the refrigerator
right before you start the assay so
points in this 96-well plate on a cold
block allows you to work with confidence
that your proteins are not degrading
over time at room temperature because
also we know that trying to set a
96-well plate on an ice bucket and then
keep the ice chips from falling into it
it's kind of a complication that you
shouldn't have to worry about and then
finally this working plate also enables
multi-channel pipetting and you'll see
why in just a second that it's so much
easier if you just take a little time to
set up this working plate so with the
working plate what you do is you in in
this example I will go through if the
user was going to run the entire 96 low
plated ones so the user basically takes
12 microliters of antibody a and adds it
to their conical tube on 12 microliters
of antibody B and then 696 microliters
of the dilution buffer all of this goes
into the tube a gentle mixture pipetting
and then even distribution across the
entire eight wells on this working plate
now the second step is to go ahead and
find all those those unknown samples you
know many times people have them on
different plates or different tubes
we're going to do is help everyone get
all that stuff gathered up and then
diluted before you even start so
basically the user will take 5
microliters and by the way they can use
2 microliters as well that's an option
but 5 microliters plus 45 or 2 plus 18
so basically either way the 10% dilution
of all of their unknowns and they go in
this part of the plate so after this
dilution step of the antibodies and the
unknown is done they're probably ready
to go ahead
and perform their standard curve and
again this protein standard that was
reconstituted basically goes right in
here in the first s1 concentration so
standard one and then the user performs
a traditional serial dilution down the
plate and as you'll see in just invent
with our cloud software we provide a lot
of flexibility for the end user to
basically decide where they want to
start their curve what's the dynamic
range they want to stretch it out maybe
do a ten point curve the hold Aleutians
the number of replicates all of that is
managed very nicely by the cloud
software
so once the working plate is made up and
you can see this actually you know
I went through and talked about it but I
think in the amount of time I was
talking a user could have finished half
of it already so basically let's go to
the next slide so once the user has the
plate setup the working place the rest
is a piece of cake and all they have to
do is basically pipette 5 microliters of
the antibodies to every well on the pcr
plate followed by 5 microliters of
protein standard or 5 microliters of
unknown samples after that's done the
person of the user basically seals the
plate mixes it and incubate at room
temperature for one hour it's third in
this one hours is that the two epitope
specific antibodies are binding the
olive oils are coming into close
proximity and then with a couple minutes
left in the one hour intubation the user
simply adds 30 micro liters of ligase to
5 mils of their master mix mix is gently
in a conical tube and then pipettes 40
microliters with a multi-channel type
header across the entire working plate
or the excuse me the entire pcr plate
then the user simply pops that plate
into the qpcr instrument for a
pre-programmed ligation inactivation and
then 40 cycles of qpcr now this is the
data you've probably been waiting for so
what we're showing here is some of the
performance compares
between pro quantum immunoassay platform
in red and a typical eliza in blue and
what I'm showing here for
gamma-interferon in aisle six is
comparing Pro quantum with a giant with
a normal non ultra sensitive Eliza
but then for aisle eight an Iowan beta
I'm actually comparing Co quantum two on
two of our ultra sensitive Eliza's and
what you can see here is is regardless
of what kind of Eliza for quantum
definitely exceeds in the area of
dynamic range as well as sensitivity
which is shown on the right hand side
here so what I'm showing is analytical
sensitivity limited detection on between
pro quantum again in red and Eliza in
blue for a number of targets that we've
already validated now what you can see
is the platform's very powerful but I'd
like to also describe or share a couple
differentiating differentiate earth that
I think are really important here and so
as an ask a developer on you know I've
always been concerned that okay we make
or acquire antibodies we label them for
our particular needs but how do we know
that what we do to the antibody is not
affecting the specificity or the
reproducibility of the assay so what we
did was we've utilized
cyclic chemistry and this is a
technology the weeds own for for a while
as a company and it was something that I
felt was being sort of underutilized and
especially in our space where we're
performing Catman amplification this is
very it's ideally suited for pro quantum
and so what site clicked is it's
basically a conjugation chemistry it's
covalent but it basically our targets
the glycosylation sites in the heavy
chains of IgG s and so because of the
chemistry there is no way to alter the
variable domains which of course confer
the specificity on an antibody and so
with cyclic chemistry we're attaching on
somewhere between three and four by
attend per LGG molecule or per on on the
average that is and so of course that
via chilling antibody is then used with
stripped avid and Allah goes to create
our antibody conjugates that are and
delivered in our pro quantum kit the
reason another reason why cyclic excites
means because I'm what I show here is a
degree of labeling experiment we're
actually measuring the average number of
by tens per antibody molecule this is
across nine different experiments and
what you see is a non specific or non
targeted labeling method can give a CV
of around anywhere on nearly 50 percent
but with the cyclic chemistry you see
here the very tight very consistent on
nine percent and so the next sense
biochemically why it's such a tight
value but then somebody might ask well
wait you know how does a tight degree of
labeling then equate to a better acid
and I think that's nicely shown on the
right-hand side here so what we see here
on the right side is basically on three
different assays for aisle ten that were
performed with non specific labeling
techniques which are in blue and then
three assays that we're using the used
cyclic chemistry that are in red and
what you can see here is with the
nonspecific sometimes you might get ace
an assay that performs like this
sometimes you might get one that
performs like this but in the case of
the site click you get one that performs
a very consistent across the board and
so that consistency is also I think it's
something that the end-user under user
should be impressed with because what
we're doing is we're passing along that
consistency and that reassurance that
the labeling chemistry arm now and ten
years down the road is never going to be
affecting those variable names
because the next thing I'd like to talk
about really quickly is basically you
know these assays we validate these
assays in natural samples so we perform
the spike recovery we do a linearity
dilution parallelism benchmarking -
Eliza we do all of those assays with all
of those on validation steps that you
have come to expect and other
immunoassay platforms and Pro kata
precaution is the same way and so what
I'm showing here in slide 14 is
basically a parallelism curve where I'm
showing the overlay of various human
serum samples along the standard curve
showing great parallelism and then also
not only for human serum but also for
PBMC supernatants RC B 3 C T 28 as well
as PMA and Ayana myosin then on the
right hand side I'm actually showing a
linearity of dilution for those saving
samples across a range and so again that
linearity of dilution helps ensure that
regardless of the dilution you're going
to get very accurate results and this is
the same type of data for a different
target i'll 17f but again we perform
these types of validation experiments
for every single target that we're
releasing and then here's just a very
brief view of some of the benchmarking
data for our various targets so
basically comparing Pro quantum on the
y-axis and Eliza's on the x-axis showing
a very strong concordance between those
two for a number of targets and we
perform again this for every target
that's being launched now finally what
I'd like to do is spend just a couple
minutes touching on the cloud software
and I think this is something where
early on I didn't think that this was
going to be such a game-changer but as I
got more involved and other colleagues
of mine that work very closely with the
cloud software development team we
realized what a huge opportunity this is
to help improve
workflow and its various steps in the
workflow that you know other software's
may crunch the data but they don't
really turn the workflow on its head in
a good way to say you know what how can
we make it so much easier and make it
different for the end-user and I think
we've done a very good job of that with
this software so what I'm showing here
just a couple screenshots I'll go
through more of it in just a minute but
for example we have a standard curve
wizard that basically goes through and
asks the user which kit they're running
what type of the number of dilution the
number of you know the dilution series
of the whole dilution the number of
replicates the number of points in the
dilution on whether it needs the working
plate needs to be set up in horizontal
or vertical format is automatically
adjusted the user also is able to
populate their unknowns in a number of
different ways and by the way what we're
showing here are three different colors
for three different groups and in fact
our software which I'll talk about
actually right here is we provide that
group wise comparison and this is a
robust em stack modified mann-whitney
group wise comparison because we know in
heterogeneous patient populations which
is very much like what people are
studying in in the translational
research space they aren't a clear
separation between let's say a diseased
group and a treatment group etc so a
simple t-test or ANOVA does not not
suffice so this modified mann-whitney
group wise comparison is very powerful
um so let me not forget to go back up
here and say that you know a lot of
people when they decide what they're
going to do in their experiment they
basically you know will copy the
protocol and scribble in it or take
notes and then you know write things
down everyone got their own little
little shortcuts to try to document what
they're doing what we've done with this
cloud specific software is we actually
go through and cut them produced a
customized lab instruction based upon
how the user filled out this initial
tej here and so that that customized lab
instruction can then be saved as a PDF
putting electronic lab notebook a
physical notebook etc so our software of
course provides all of the standard
calculations for concentrations for
because this is a pacman based readout
of course we have all the amplification
curves we provide the 5 PL curve fitting
for those 1/4 PL we provide that as well
we provide outlier detection for
unknowns and standards based on certain
criteria and so let me just reiterate
here that all of this is possible on any
qPCR instrument even if your instrument
does not create an es file which is the
case for any applied Biosystems
instrument all you need is a excel file
with all the CP values in it we can
import that digest it and analyze it on
just like if it was a applied Biosystems
instrument and then finally let me just
say that what we're doing is we're also
making this software graphpad prism
friendly what that means is that you can
actually save the data file so that it
actually can then be opened up in
graphpad prism and then you can make go
ahead and make your various figures and
graphs that you may need for publication
purposes or a poster etc we know myself
included I love that prism and so it's
one of those things that making it
easier to basically open up the file so
you don't have to retype or sort of do
an interesting copy and paste
transformation to get the data in there
we've tried to make that very very easy
so without any additional delay let me
go ahead and open up my browser window
here so I can actually share my browser
and show everyone how this really
quickly works ok so let's get started so
what the user will see so they've
already got let's say they've already
signed up for a free thermal Fisher
cloud
and so when they open the pro quantum
out this is what we're going to see two
choices create an experiment or import
new results so if the user has already
created a plate map um they would go
directly here but for a new user
everyone's going to get started right
here
the first thing you see is okay a
catalog number so you know for this
example let's type in our il-6 catalog
number so a three five five seven three
voila you type it in you get the species
the analyte of course the lot number
will be specific the user can type that
in it gives a recommended stock
concentration the number of dilution the
rate of dilution the number of
replicates etc now in this case let's
say a customer a user or even somebody
like one of our athlete of ella purrs on
my team we really want to push the
limits of this assay so what do we do we
basically want to start the assay at a
5,000 we want to do a tenfold dilution
so there you go the working plate
changes to a horizontal and you know
what let's go ahead and we'll still goo
on triplicates so now we move on it says
how the software actually goes through
and says how many unknowns we now want
so basically you can go through by the
way we always recommend a tenfold
dilution the number of samples you can
actually choose singlet duplicate trump
and you know quadruple get and so
basically if you wanted to do with
singlets you can actually go ahead and
type in all 60 here and it auto fills
everything but let's say okay the
customer or the user now wants to
basically you know what they always like
to have a little bit of a gap between
their standard curve and their unknown
so you can basically clear the selected
wells and it will go ahead and you can
adjust it accordingly and let's go ahead
and save that for armed but this is the
sake of this let's just call this
webinar so what we're saving here is
actually the plate map okay so what I'm
going to show here this is the
customized lab instructions that I spoke
of so basically what we see here as
basic is the quick reference card and in
a more customized format so the first
thing chill the reagents whether you're
doing the five micro liter or the two
micro liter volume um the reason that's
important is down here whether you're
doing a 5 micro liter si or if you're
doing a 2 micro liter si you see that
the volumes even for how to dilute your
samples it went from four to it's two
plus 18 for five it's five plus 45 right
down here on the amount of sample
required for the plate is already pre
calculated remember earlier for a five
micro litre assay it said you know 12
plus 12 plus six 96 well we're doing
just a little bit less than the whole
plate so you can see that these numbers
even have even changed now at the very
bottom you see the cycling conditions
and so for example on 15 second
denaturation and a 1-minute annealing
extension that is actually for a
standard block or what we know as the
0.2 mil standard block but of course if
you have the fast block the 0.1 milk
block you can actually see even the
cycling conditions go down to 3 seconds
and 30 seconds so again these lab
instructions are completely customized
you can save them as a PDF you can print
them out and paste them into your lab
notebook etc ok so now the plate map has
been saved you saved your lab
instructions you go off run the
experiment and then basically you come
back and upload the cloud data and so
basically you can import from your
computer here you select the EDS file
and here we go we actually have the
plate we've already saved the plate map
we apply that plate map so basically
upload progress the file was
successfully uploaded it actually gives
the software get you one more
opportunity because we all know we
at the bench where we've done an
experiment and then we decided at the
last minute you know what I changed our
mind I want to do a different curve I
want to run different samples etc and by
the way so I didn't go back and renumber
these so it looks like this one's
starting with unknown 13 and goes to 60
I should have remembered them because I
deleted this first row of singlets but
you know the user could go back and they
wanted to remember those um but in the
interest of time I don't want to belabor
this so let's just go onward you know
that in this particular example unknown
13 is our first unknown so you click
Next now if I had changed something in
the plate layout it would actually give
the software would give me an
opportunity to go ahead and save it
under a different name so maybe I call
it experiment 1 and then experiment 1 a
if I decided ok so here it's already
analyzed the software or our be analyzed
the l.e.d.s file so in that time I was
if I was talking it basically took the
plate map overlaid it on the EDS file
and here we go here's the standard curve
showing a wonderful by Namek range as
the lower and upper ends we actually
have red here it's because the outlier
parameters indicate possibly a CV that
is greater than 15% or a recovery that's
outside the 70 to 130 so the user can
actually go through and decide whether
or not they want to apply certain
outlier parameters or we have a more
rigorous algorithm with that was
designed by one of our biostatisticians
but in this particular example let's
just leave it as is so now we go ahead
and just click Next and apply the
existing by the way here's where we
would also if the user wanted 4pl
instead of 5 PL you could also click on
that and recalculate um so let's go
ahead and click Next and now what you'll
see okay here's the curve still but
actually since we're not really
interested in looking at that curve
anymore we've already validated the
standard curve let's go ahead and look
at the data so we can actually toggle
this to look at all of the data table
information so we have theoretical
concentration measured concentration
percent recoveries
we can sort by basically the different
standards and what we're looking at here
is the average view you could actually
select the replicants as well and so
basically what we're seeing here is s1
through f10 and so yeah what you see
here is s10 was actually a 131 percent
so yeah it was one percent over that 70
to 130 window that's why it was flagged
as an outlier okay so you can go through
here scroll back and forth you can
actually look at particular unknowns so
let's pick an unknown here and by the
way you can look at the amp curves you
can actually see the amp curve for
various unknowns here and a lot of
people that are very familiar with
pac-man genomic assays are very
accustomed to look into the amp curves
and so they can be used for
troubleshooting purposes or better
understand subtle differences etc um and
so what's important also note here is
that if you want to download all the
data into excel let's say you want to do
something else with it or you want the
PNG files of all of the standard curves
so it'll actually go through and
download all of those separate
attachments for you um and so yeah I
mean this is pretty much it you go
through and by the way arm okay in this
particular example all of the unknowns
are in one group but actually you know
what the person might have said you know
what forgot to design my my my different
group wise comparison so you know what
we can go back to plate layout and let's
go ahead and put this group call it
group one call this one let's say group
two and then call this one Group three
okay and so this is the classic example
somebody runs the experiment they say oh
shoot I forgot um
I should have you know listed the
different group names so now go back
through we can call it group and what
it's going to go back through is just
basically go through that qualify
standard again but what I wanted to show
is basically that group wise comparison
so bear with me distress
and here as it recalculates but what you
can see here is in the amount of time
that I've been able to import the EDS
file click on the various you know
outlier criteria etc this is very rapid
and so what you see here now are the
three various groups and The Associated
p-values with those groups and again
this is the man would mean group wise
comparison so again you can see very
quickly we can very powerful results
okay so I'm going to pop out of this
real quick back to the slide deck and
what you can see here is I should be on
slide 18 so again I'd like to wrap up
I'm very excited if you can't tell
already of the you know we've been able
to share this with you we first unveiled
this this platform just last month at
the American Association for
immunologist meeting we I had a lot of
great feedback from people in our booth
and a workshop we gave so again I think
this is a platform that meets a lot of
needs it's long overdue for people and
it's quick easy and very powerful and so
again it allows that end user to measure
very small sample amounts in a very
small sample and I think being able to
get those answers
in a very short amount of time is also
just as important and of course that is
made possible with a very powerful cloud
enabled platform what you're going to
see from us over over this summer is
basically please stay tuned for a lot of
early adopter stories as people start to
use this platform and definitely you
know come back and check us out you'll
see
we're basically you're going to have
teaser videos all this this webinar will
be made available of in subsequent
months but definitely make sure to check
us out at thermo Fisher comm slash
explore and then also remember don't
don't forget to apply for your
free from a Fisher cloud account and
start familiarizing yourself with the
pro Quantum app and definitely you know
we look forward to working with all of
those end users I'll be on the road
talking about this my colleagues have
been trained on this and they're very
excited to share this with you as well
and so definitely stay tuned as you can
learn more about this product in the
coming months so again thank you very
much for your attention I hope you learn
something from this and see pro quantum
as a next-generation immunoassay
platform that you can benefit from and
definitely you know look forward to to
sharing more in the coming months thank
you very much thank you for that
presentation dr. Borden we want to get
right to your questions and inputs so
here's a reminder as to how audience
members can communicate with us
questions can be submitted via the Q&A
button at the lower left
if we are unable to get to your
questions due to due to time constraint
there's no official scientific will
reach out to you via email and our first
question is can these assays be
multi-plex you know that's a very good
question um to put it what we know but
let me exceed this so whether or not you
were performing a profit multiplex
immunoassay for example trying to
measure 30 to 60 analytes in a single
well know per quantum cannot do that and
it wasn't designed to do that um we have
an amazing beat based technology called
Ricardo Plex it's based on the luminex
backbone and we should be you know the
customers should be going to that type
of immunoassay platform first definitely
it has it's very powerful right now we
have a 65 Plex that can actually be
customized up to 80
flex and so pro quantum definitely does
not replace that now what it can do
though is because it only uses a very
small amount of sample and so in the
example I've shown today you can imagine
sort of combining the two different
scenarios so let's say you take 5
microliters dilute it to a total of 50
but then you do a 2 microliter assay so
without accounting for any slopper or
excess you might need for pipetting you
know in theory you can run 25 replicate
wells so let's say you know to be safe
you could run 20 replicate wells with
that single 5 micro liter of diluted
sample so you can actually perform those
assays in parallel and because we are
offering a 384-well format you can
imagine you can fit a lot of well on 384
well plate so it's not true multiplexing
in the exact same well but it's
important to note that when bead base
multiplex assays are made like a Luminex
platform based assay sometimes
compromises have to be made on which
antibodies to use because you also have
to make sure that there's no cross
reactivity because you're trying to
measure each of the analytes all
together in one well well sometimes you
may have to pass on certain antibodies
that could give greater sensitivity and
the course in in the case of per quantum
we don't have to worry about that we're
able to settle on the best antibody that
not only gives us the great performance
in terms of sensitivity but also meets
the strict criteria for spike recovery
parallelism etc so definitely keeping
the DMM detection separate can sometimes
be beneficial and so there is a way to
do parallel parallel measurements
there's no washed-up cause higher
background increased nonspecific binding
you know that's a natural question a lot
of people see that cartoon that I show
with the the two antibodies and the hour
goes and free solution and people just
naturally assume that if the Y base is
present with those two antibodies and
free solutions you're just going to
naturally ligate those two all of those
together even when the antibodies aren't
bound to analyte and the answer is that
that there's very little of that
happening of course the no protein
control that's the amount of signal you
get in the absence of protein so we do
account for removing out the background
with any assay platform course there's a
miniscule amount of background but no
the to Allah goes do not lie gate to
each other in the absence of protein
because again it's that stabilization of
the antibodies and the analyte it
requires everything to slow down so that
the to Allah goes can be joined together
with the DNA ligase so it looks like we
have time for one more question the
sensitivity improvement overnight
incubation yeah that's a good question
it depends upon the assay so if the
assay is utilizing two monoclonal
antibodies we find that there's very
little improvement in performance by
incubating overnight now when I was
showing the workflow side slide what I
should have said though is yeah it's
very compatible it's very possible a
user can perform that incubation either
at one hour room temperature or just
naturally place each plate at four
degrees overnight it's not it's never
going to hurt the assay and so in the
case of mono mono pairs we see that the
sensitivity
permit is negligible however if a
particular assay is using a monoclonal
and a polyclonal antibody
we've actually seen that yes there can
be some improvement by performing the
the assay the incubation overnight at 4
degrees now just so let everyone know
the performance criteria that we are
reporting is always for the 1-hour assay
so in particular cases yeah the end-user
can try incubating at 4 degrees
overnight you may get an improved
sensitivity over what we already have
which is very good but again it depends
upon the assay and yeah so you know I
think it's important to note that
incubating a little bit longer can never
hurt it's just in particular cases like
a mono mono pair it doesn't really
improve it at all thank you again dr.
David Borden I would also like to thank
lab groups for making today's
educational webcast possible today's
webcast will be available for on-demand
until May 2018 keep an eye out for an
email from laberd's alerting you when
the subtest will be available for replay
we encourage you to forward that
announcement to your colleagues who may
have missed today's live event thank you
for joining us and we hope to see you
next time goodbye